all right ripping up the outline on the
fly because we kind of tripped over this
conversation regarding destinations for
philip rivers the tampa bay buccaneers a
potential place where he can land
because jameis winston's future there is
in doubt and peter you are right 30
interceptions and that history of being
reckless with the football he's got a
bad habit of trying to do more than his
body will allow him to do
that is balanced by
5109 passing yards in
2019
eighth all time the only human beings
who have had more passing yards in a
season than jameis winston are peyton
manning drew brees tom brady and ben
roethlisberger that's it
so if you're the buccaneers how do you
reconcile that you're going to give up
that production
uh in lieu of trying to reduce the
interceptions or are the interceptions
incurable maybe only bruiserians knows
the answer to that question
well mike i've got about 48 comments and
we've only got about an hour and 45
minutes left in the show so i'm gonna go
over okay here comes a filibuster look
everybody knows that jameis winston when
he's hot and having a big day can throw
for 400 yards soaking matthew stafford
soaking case keenum okay i mean you know
it's not
so hard today
all those numbers i'm sure have happened
in the last 15 or 18 years right all
those people have thrown for 5 000 yards
i forget the first year it happened but
i remember a few years ago going to
packers training camp and talking to
aaron rodgers about how soon it will be
before somebody throws for 6 000 yards
somebody will it's football
and and mike the biggest thing
about jameis winston you can talk about
50 100 yards but let me ask you this
question how would you like to have a
quarterback who threw
for 4 100 yards
and threw
16 or 18 fewer interceptions i'll take
that any day of the week it's about
possessing the ball and moving down the
field with the ball
how do you account for throwing 50 100
yards and then account for the
interceptions that you threw that stop
drives
and that is the thing that i don't care
if he threw for 5 900 yards and 30
interceptions it would not make up for
the 30 interceptions
he simply makes too many errors and all
i'm saying is that i'd be on the fence
right now whether i was gonna pay him
significantly anyway
but
to pay him a lot of money
and lock yourself into a guy
who has made more mistakes over the last
five years by far did any start starting
quarterback in football
it makes no sense
frankly i don't want either jameis
winston or phillip rivers for 2020. i
want to aim higher than both guys but i
don't want to take away from 50 109
yards that is a historic achievement
when you only have four human beings
whoever walked the planet who have had
more production than that one single
season so what means how many guys in
modern football have thrown 30
interceptions how many not many any
when's the last time a guy threw 30
interceptions in a year
but and i don't i don't disagree with
that side of it but if he's only thrown
4 000 yards and 30 interceptions to me
that's far worth it then he wouldn't be
on the team there's something there
there's something to work on and of
course there is there's been something
there for five years we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports